hey guys how's it going it's Justine and
guess who I'm with today the king of
random grant Thompson and today this is
something that I'm calling the eBay
revenge so this is a 3ds that I got on
eBay that said that it was new in the
box and that was a lie I wasn't a lot of
Apple products before this is not the
handiwork of an original unboxed iPhone
I brought down to LA my backyard metal
foundry now this is a trashcan that I've
lined with Kol so it can now resist
temperatures up to around 2500 degrees
Fahrenheit which should be well above
the melting point of your plastics
iPhone casing there we also have another
one you guys might remember this it was
a few vidcon's ago this phone we
actually stuck in this big chomping fake
shark shark we get chomped my phone
hopefully I can find that video I'll
show you guys that my baby I poured it
went right through the Jeep but today
we're getting revenge on the eBay lying
scammers we're going to fire this thing
up we're going to get one of our
crucibles ripping hot and we're going to
take this broken scammy iPhone and we're
going to throw it down inside the
foundry it's exactly what happened
[Music]
let's get temperatures that will melt
the metal probably not if the frame is
made of steel you know what's going to
happen yeah we really don't know what's
going to happen any comparator go light
it up so light it up
[Music]
so this founder that we've got has two
propane jets we're running up from a
propane tank back here a 20-pound
cylinder like you use for barbecuing
we've got both of the valves open and
we're going to shoot the Jetson and
light them and it's going to create a
swirling vortex of fire and this
crucible is going to sit right inside
here and it's going to turn glowing
red-hot Wow yeah let's test it out with
a broken one because I really don't want
to even give this one up even though it
is how high you want to really want to
put the switch again okay so high yep
you should so how safe is this not
nothing no it's okay like from a
distance if your head is over top of it
you might lose that beautiful hair
promises and we don't want we don't want
to touch the hair
[Music]
whoa okay wait now it's for gonna shot
oh the lid here is line to scale wolves
well that's going to go on proper form
an insulating barrier just like this
we've got propane that's getting in
there it's air in for the Jets
and then it's lighting it and coming up
to the top and this thing is going from
cold which is like 85 90 degrees today
or we get up to about 2200 degrees in a
matter of up in there wow this is
absolutely insane do not try this at
home
do not
today today oh you're glad you get I got
discovered
famous last words and we're gonna leave
this for about 10 to 15 minutes and let
it heat this is that crucible right now
is the same temperature as house where
comes right now about 90 degrees we raid
that to about 2200 degrees you got your
phone quick update guys the county's
been roaring for about 15 minutes now
that's given it enough time to come up
to temperature so it is ready to go yeah
it's ready for recite the talk today
let's go do it
[Music]
now the closer you want to put the phone
now you okay I'm going to put on this
Idol just going to clip it in the
columns here we're going to take the lid
off the battery and gently lower down to
the crucible and see what it does
would you like to take the lid off
okay I call air going up on oh no
problem
down back because that battery might
explode let me take the lid put it back
on you can see that thing will live with
the phone in there I don't know I don't
know I'm not sure how I feel I don't
know if I scared or like I just kept
looking at I'm just afraid this is
obviously a very very new experience way
outside of your comfort zone I don't get
comfortable I think that's the best way
to put it
so justin is going to hang on there for
I'll give you an update the phone I
think is completely melted or whatever
it's done because the flames look died
down everything's returned to normal
let's go ahead and take the lid off now
the exactly where you got luck in our
personal
oh wow look at the phone is not where
the trigana pride it's like almost like
a flirtation in a fire like the pages
appeal back
the peeled off
who died
the frame of your phone
back in school day I'm kind of thinking
that brain must be made of stainless
steel or something probably is because
it sucks that word aluminum that thing
would have melted completely the glass
is gone I couldn't bring myself to break
this one even though I got scammed I'm
sooo attached baby
I think we've been running for about 25
to 30 minutes so if anything is going to
happen it will have already happened we
go ahead and reveal this and whatever we
got is what we've got
I don't know what that is part of the
treatment
oh my god welcome to class we have
molten glass in there incredible yes
who that is toasty that is hot stuff
what do you think well your sirens I
wonder if they're coming to my house oh
my gosh you're right
Oh we'll get all this packed up and way
before the dish we did nothing there's
still stuff glowing and bubbling in
there looks absolutely insane come take
us out look at this
it's actually got a pleasant aroma
almost like a campfire out in the middle
of the woods I wish I had some sticks we
could roast marshmallows
there's your iPhone frame Justine that's
pretty crazy so it definitely must have
been shameless kill ya or steal of some
sort so this is the iPhone 3GS this
piece of metal that resisted and if
these were aluminium they would have
melted for sure oh look there's the
battery oh boy that's safe somehow the
metal on the battery survived I'm glad
that didn't explode on us there's a
screen right there Wow yep there's the
iPhone 3GS yeah that's the screen so
completely liquefied and then hardened
up again as a big ball of crystal glass
in metal that's pretty cool Wow
that right there is the screen for the
iPhone melted into glass and stuck to
the bottom of crystal that's pretty
awesome
I bought these a long time ago for
another cooking video and clearly it
will happen these are the Jumbo hollows
there's a king of random cooking video
here we go you see what happens how much
residual heat do we have on that furnace
there I think a lot cuz I can feel it
from here savers out how close can we
get before it starts different who I can
smell that it actually smells quite nice
oh my gosh this is the best way to make
marshmallow its toasted why does that
smell incredible
the smell really good wow that's like
the most perfect toasted marshmallow
I've ever seen very good to see thank
you nothing like backyard barbecue good
now we just need some chocolate and some
graham crackers and we've got a hot
s'more a molten hot s'more oh good
it's going on good it tastes like iPhone
so looks like the things that survives
with a little piece of the inside we've
got the frame which is definitely some
sort of steel because that did not melt
at all which is kind of crazy yeah I
haven't melted copper with this thing
but I've never been able to melt steel
it has a really high melting point but
what blows me away is that the screen
like the actual glass melted down and
floated the bottom of crucible and so we
were actually able to melt a glass which
I'm very proud of did that completely
very awesome never tried before really
worse well here we are we did it I know
you guys probably were expecting me to
throw in the one that I got off of ebay
but something was a pretty perfect phone
I couldn't bring myself to do it but
this is my eBay revenge on the old phone
that actually didn't work take that be
BAE in your face thank you guys so much
for watching and a huge thank you to
grant make sure you go check out his
channel we've also done some super crazy
videos on his channel as well and it was
super night and we just tried freezing a
computer with liquid nitrogen to see if
it would survive what do you guys think
do you think it will survive I don't
know you'll have to watch the video let
me know what other videos you might want
me to make because I don't think I can
ever top anything like this maybe we can
come back and do it again yes my mom for
me
whoo yeah my god
[Music]
you